Occidental College in California is
considering instituting a system for
students to report so-called
microaggressions perpetrated against
them on campus microaggressions are
statements that intentionally or
unintentionally send a negative message
related to someone's membership in a
marginalized group we visited campus to
ask Occidental students if they agree
that the following statements could be
considered microaggressions
they've all been documented as such on a
college campus somewhere in the United
States have you heard of the term
microaggression yeah that's a big thing
on campus if we see large-scale violence
we can name that as a macro aggression
but the way that we devalue that
violence the way that we silenced that
violence that's a micro aggression I'm
asking an asian-american where were you
born yes very very contextual you know
that's not a micro aggression that's
just asking whether we'll pull telling a
black student that he or she is very
articulate that is about saying all
lives matter
um I think because the history behind
black lives matter it's kind of like
appropriating a statement that was
created specifically to talk about black
lives being lost to police brutality so
that is I'm colorblind I don't see race
I believe the most qualified person
should get the job qualifications aren't
really the only the only things you
consider when hiring someone if you're
saying that the most qualified person is
someone who is not a minority you're not
a religion you believe in then yes I'd
be microaggression saying god bless you
after somebody sneezes oh that would be
a microaggression
because of different religions yeah it
could be a microaggression to someone
who doesn't believe in God I think that
the harm there is relatively minimal so
there's still some harm though
I would say there's not harmed but if
it's being asked clearly someone found
maybe mini microaggression perhaps do
you see any downside to creating a
database full of statements that faculty
and students make to each other in terms
of protecting free speech values on
campus not in terms of protecting free
speech value but the idea of a database
certainly raises eyebrows so yes we do
need a system where we can report our
experiences and that like a system of
education or whatever I would say it's
good to have it in place but to have
like harsh accents against it
it wouldn't be beneficial to student
life it it'll make a safer environment
so I fully support the council and I
think it's really great that the faculty
is taking this initiative because it
wasn't one of the demands the faculty on
their own said like we're gonna do this
because we believe it's what we should
be doing I'm sorry went above and beyond
to police hate speech I think so in some
respects protests are erupting on
college campuses across the country as
students demand that administrators
address racial grievances through
mandatory sensitivity training courses
hiring of more diverse faculty members
and the resignation of insufficiently
responsive college presidents change
comes from listening learning Karen
video captured at Yale University show a
student shouting down a professor trying
to engage her in conversation about the
role of faculty in regulating students
Halloween costumes this professor's wife
also a faculty member later resigned
from Yale saying the current climate at
Yale is not in my views conducive to
civil dialogue and open inquiry another
clip out of the University of Missouri
shows students and at least one
professor pushing journalists out of
their self-styled safe space
you need to get out you need to get out
so I don't
while these protesters are clearly
exercising their First Amendment rights
images such as these have led more and
more observers to wonder whether or not
college students care about the free
speech rights of others what are your
thoughts on the concept of free speech
do you support free speech yes I do
support free speech and oxys an
environment that also supports differing
opinions free speech allows you to have
new input constantly and I think that's
like a really big part of the community
Roxie Obama actually says actually
encouraged that's saying that instead of
college students being coddled they
should have these active discussions so
that they can learn something new and
change their viewpoints a little bit too
much Century censorship would give a lot
of power to few individuals and I
believe in a more even distribution of
power I think that everyone should be
able to say what they believe in what's
on their mind most of the students we
spoke with seemed to defend free speech
in principle if not always in practice
but one organizer of the previous week's
protests viewed even the concept of free
speech with deep suspicion those using
the rhetoric of free speech are
individuals who already are in positions
of power who are creating history who
are creating these dominant narratives
free speech conceptually is about this
idea of equality that everyone can have
the right to say something but that's
not the way our society works that's not
the way this college campuses work we
only hear the same reiteration of
particular voices over and over again
and that's white students voices that's
President beech his voice a recent Pew
poll found that 95 percent of Americans
believe citizens should have the right
to criticize government policies
publicly but the numbers weakened when
you start talking about offensive speech
40 percent of Millennials polled
believes that the government should be
able to prevent people from making
statements that are offensive to
minority groups for instance if it's a
racist remark or something that tries to
stir up the public I think that is that
should be stopped I think if the speech
involves a threat or involve violence of
any type then that should not be allowed
but other than that I don't think there
should be like a regulation on that
personally I think that if you ever say
someone you know I hate you because
you're so and so that's it you know that
should not be allowed in a way it's free
speech but in a way again it's a hate
crime if you're saying you're a lesser
person because you're a Muslim Jewish
Christian Catholic any of the above
that's not okay and that's a hate crime
that's the other thing about free speech
when I say that it's about power and
privilege it only enables like things
like hate speech because it makes it
seem that like everything that we say
has equal weight when that's that's not
true don't want to single out Donald
Trump but his approach to this political
campaign like saying we should monitor
some mosques we should build this wall
and keep out all the Mexicans because
they bring that gangs they bring all
that crime that kind of speech is really
hurtful to those people for no reason
just because he wants to get his views
across and Donald Trump shouldn't be
allowed to say those things personally I
wouldn't say so just because like a lot
of other people I don't really think
that he has the capabilities of being a
president or what kind of repercussions
would you like to see for hate speech
violations
now I haven't really thought about that
to be honest I think that in no way
should we like send someone to prison
for that but I think that there should
be protection of people who are being
attacked what we say in terms of hate
speech has incredible weight right
because it's an intimately linked to
violence against people of color it's
intimately linked to the prison
industrial complex do you think free
speech is valued on this campus yeah I
think it is you feel that free speech is
alive and well on the campus of Occident
yes the only thing that I do know now is
that you're in we're in a position where
you can't ignore what's going on on this
campus and that's kind of the bottom
line so students have been turning a
blind eye for a while now whether it's
whether or not they're using a
justification of free speech that's on
them
if I were to sneeze and you said god
bless you to me could that be a
microaggression
I want to say no but at the same time I
guess it would count